I know mr. president the floor is yours
to give your Nobel lecture your
Majesties your Royal Highnesses
distinguished members of the Norwegian
Nobel Committee citizens of America and
citizens of the world I receive this
honor with deep gratitude and great
humility it's an award that speaks to
our highest aspirations that for all the
cruelty and hardship of our world we are
not mere prisoners of fate our actions
matter and can bend history in the
direction of justice and yet I would be
remiss if I did not acknowledge the
considerable controversy that your
generous decision has generated in part
this is because I am at the beginning
and not the end of my Labor's on the
world stage compared to some of the
Giants of history who have received this
prize Schweitzer and King Marshall and
Mandela my accomplishments are slight
and then there are the men and women
around the world who've been jailed then
beaten in the pursuit of justice those
who toil in humanitarian organizations
to relieve suffering the unrecognized
millions who's quiet acts of courage and
compassion inspire even the most
hardened cynics I cannot argue with
those who find these men and women some
known some obscure to all but those they
help to be far more deserving of this
honor than
but perhaps the most profound issue
surrounding my receipt of this prize is
the fact that I am the commander in
chief of the military of the nation in
the midst of two wars one of these wars
is winding down the other is a conflict
that America did not seek one in which
we are joined by 42 other countries
including Norway in an effort to defend
ourselves in all nations from further
attacks still we are at war and I'm
responsible for the deployment of
thousands of young Americans to battle
in a distant land some will kill and
some will be killed and so I come here
with an acute sense of the costs of
armed conflict filled with difficult
questions about the relationship between
war and peace and our effort to replace
one with the other now these questions
are not new war in one form or another
appeared with the first man at the dawn
of history since morality was not
questioned it was simply a fact like
drought or disease the manner in which
tribes and then civilizations sought
power and settled their differences and
over time as codes of law sought to
control violence within groups
so did philosophers and clerics and
statesmen seek to regulate the
destructive power of war the concept of
a just war emerged suggesting that war
is justified only when certain
conditions were met if it is waged as a
last resort or in self-defense
if the force used is proportional and if
whenever possible civilians are spared
from violence of course we know that for
most
this concept of just war was rarely
observed the capacity of human beings to
think of new ways to kill one another
proved inexhaustible as did our capacity
to exempt from mercy those who look
different or prey to a different God
wars between armies gave way to wars
between nations total wars in which the
distinction between combatant and
civilian became blurred in the span of
thirty years such carnage would twice
engulf this continent and while it's
hard to conceive of a cause more just
than the defeat of the Third Reich and
the Axis powers World War two was a
conflict in which the total number of
civilians who died exceeded the number
of soldiers who perished in the wake of
such destruction and with the advent of
the nuclear age it became clear to
Victor and vanquished alike
that the world needed institutions to
prevent another world war and so a
quarter century after the United States
Senate rejected the League of Nations an
idea for which Woodrow Wilson received
this prize America led the world in
constructing an architecture to keep the
peace a Marshall Plan and a United
Nations mechanisms to govern the waging
of war treaties to protect human rights
prevent genocide restrict the most
dangerous weapons in many ways these
efforts succeeded yes terrible wars have
been fought and atrocities committed but
there has been no third world war the
Cold War ended with jubilant crowds
dismantling a wall commerce has stitched
much of the world together billions have
been lifted from poverty the ideals of
liberty and self-determination
equality and the rule of law have
haltingly advanced we are the heirs of
the fortitude and foresight of
generations past and it is the legacy
for which my own country is rightfully
proud and yet a decade into a new
century this old architecture is
buckling under the weight of new threats
the world may no longer shudder at the
prospect of war between two nuclear
superpowers but proliferation may
increase the risk of catastrophe
terrorism has long been a tactic but
modern technology allows a few small men
without size rage to murder innocents on
a horrific scale
moreover wars between nations have
increasingly given way to wars within
nations the resurgence of ethnic or
sectarian conflicts the growth of
secessionist movements insurgencies and
failed States all these things have
increasingly trapped civilians in
unending chaos in today's wars many more
civilians are killed than soldiers the
seeds of future conflict are sown
economies are wrecked civil societies
torn asunder refugees amassed children
scarred I do not bring with me today a
definitive solution to the problems of
war what I do know is that meeting these
challenges will require the same vision
hard work and persistence of those men
and women who acted so boldly decades
ago and it will require us to think in
new ways about the notions of Just War
and the imperatives of a just peace
we must begin by acknowledging a hard
truth we will not eradicate violent
conflict in our lifetimes there will be
times when nations acting individually
or in concert will find the use of force
not only necessary but morally justified
I make this statement mindful of what
Martin Luther King jr. said in this same
ceremony years ago violence never brings
permanent peace it solves no social
problem that merely creates new and more
complicated ones as someone who stands
here as a direct consequence of dr.
King's as life work I am living
testimony to the moral force of
non-violence I know there's nothing weak
nothing passive nothing naive in the
Creed and lives of Gandhi and King but
as a head of state sworn to protect and
defend my nation I cannot be guided by
their examples alone I face the world as
it is and cannot stand idle in the face
of threats to the American people for
make no mistake evil does exist in the
world a non-violent movement could not
have halted Hitler's armies negotiations
cannot convince Al Qaeda's leaders to
lay down their arms to say that force
may sometimes be necessary is not a call
to cynicism it is a recognition of
history the imperfections of man and the
limits of reason I raised this point I
begin with this point because in many
countries there is a deep ambivalence
about military action today no matter
what the cause and at times this is
joined by a reflexive suspicion of
America
the world's sole military superpower yet
the world must remember that it was not
simply international institutions not
just treaties and declarations that
brought stability to a post-world War
two
world whatever mistakes we have made the
plain fact is this the United States of
America has helped underwrite global
security for more than six decades with
the blood of our citizens and the
strength of our arms the service and
sacrifice of our men and women in
uniform has promoted peace and
prosperity from Germany to Korea and
enabled democracy to take hold in places
like the Balkans we have borne this
burden not because we seek to impose our
will we have done so out of enlightened
self-interest because we seek a better
future for our children and
grandchildren and we believe that their
lives will be better if others children
and grandchildren can live in freedom
and prosperity
so yes the instruments of war do have a
role to play in preserving the peace and
yet this truth must coexist with another
that no matter how justified war
promises human tragedy the soldier's
courage and sacrifice is full of glory
expressing devotion to country to cause
to comrades in arms but war itself is
never glorious and we must never trumpet
it as such so part of our challenge is
reconciling these two seemingly in
reconcilable truths that war is
sometimes necessary and war at some
level is an expression
of human folly concretely we must direct
our effort to the task that President
Kennedy called for long ago let us focus
he said on a more practical more
attainable peace based not on a sudden
revolution in human nature but on a
gradual evolution in human institutions
a gradual evolution of human
institutions what might this evolution
look like what might these practical
steps be to begin with I believe that
all nations strong and weak alike must
adhere to standards that govern the use
of force I like any head of state
reserve the right to act unilaterally if
necessary to defend my nation
nevertheless I am convinced that
adhering to standards international
standards strengthens those who do and
isolates and weakens those who don't the
world rallied around America after the
9/11 attacks and continues to support
our efforts in Afghanistan because of
the horror of those senseless attacks
and the recognized principle of
self-defense likewise the world
recognized the need to confront Saddam
Hussein when he invaded Kuwait a
consensus that sent a clear message to
all about the cost of aggression
furthermore America in fact no nation
can insist that others follow the rules
of the road if we refuse to follow them
ourselves for when we don't our actions
appear arbitrary and undercut the
legitimacy of future interventions no
matter how justified and this becomes
particularly important when the purpose
of military action extends beyond self
defense or defense of one
nation against an aggressive more and
more we all confront difficult questions
about how to prevent the slaughter of
civilians by their own government or to
stop a Civil War whose violence and
suffering can involve engulf an entire
region I believe that force can be
justified on humanitarian grounds as it
was in the Balkans or in other places
that have been scarred by war inaction
tears at our conscience and can lead to
more costly intervention later that's
why all responsible nations must embrace
the role that militaries with a clear
mandate can play to keep the peace
America's commitment to global security
will never waver but in a world in which
threats are more diffuse and missions
more complex America cannot act alone
America alone cannot secure the peace
this is true in Afghanistan this is true
in failed states like Somalia where
terrorism and piracy is joined by famine
and human suffering and sadly it will
continue to be true in unstable regions
for years to come the leaders and
soldiers of NATO countries and other
friends and allies demonstrate this
truth through the capacity and courage
they've shown in Afghanistan but in many
countries there is a disconnect between
the efforts of those who serve and the
ambivalence of the broader public I
understand why war is not popular but I
also know this the belief that peace is
desirable is rarely enough to achieve it
peace requires responsibility peace
entails sacrifice
that's why NATO continues to be
indispensable that's why we must
strengthen UN and regional peacekeeping
and not leave the task to a few
countries that's why we honor though
who returned home from peacekeeping and
training abroad to Oslo and Rome to
Ottawa and Sydney to Dakin Kigali we
honor them not as makers of war but as
of wagers
but as wagers of peace let me make one
final point about the use of force even
as we make difficult decisions about
going to war we must also think clearly
about how we fight it the Nobel
Committee recognized this truth in
awarding its first prize for peace -
Henry - not the founder of the Red Cross
and a driving force behind the Geneva
Conventions where force is necessary we
have a moral and strategic interest in
binding ourselves to certain rules of
conduct and even as we confront a
vicious adversary that abides by no
rules I believe the United States of
America must remain a standard bear in
the conduct of war that is what makes us
different from those whom we fight that
is a source of our strength that is why
I prohibited torture that is why I
ordered the prison at Guantanamo Bay
closed and that is why I have reaffirmed
America's commitment to abide by the
Geneva Conventions we lose ourselves
when we compromise the very ideals that
we fight to defend
and we honor we honor those ideals by
upholding them now what it's easy but
when it is hard I've spoken at some
length to the question that must weigh
on our minds and our hearts as we choose
to wage war but let me now turn to our
effort to avoid such tragic choices and
speak of three ways that we can build a
just and lasting peace first in dealing
with those nations that break rules and
laws I believe that we must develop
alternatives to violence that are tough
enough to actually change behavior for
if we want a lasting peace then the
words of the international community
must mean something those regimes that
break the rules must be held accountable
sanctions must exact a real price
intransigence must be met with increased
pressure and such pressure exists only
when the world stands together as one
one urgent example is the effort to
prevent the spread of nuclear weapons
and to seek a world without them in the
middle of the last century nations agree
to be bound by a treaty whose bargain is
clear all will have access to peaceful
nuclear power those without nuclear
weapons will forsake them and those with
nuclear weapons will work towards
disarmament I am committed to upholding
this treatment it is a centerpiece of my
foreign policy and I'm working with
President Medvedev to reduce America and
Russia's nuclear stockpiles but it's
also incumbent upon all of us to insist
that nations like Iran and North Korea
do not gain the system those who claim
to respect international law cannot
avert their eyes when those laws are
floated
those who care for their own security
cannot ignore the danger of an arms race
in the Middle East or East Asia those
who seek peace cannot stand idly by as
nations arm themselves for nuclear war
the same principle applies to those who
violate international laws by
brutalizing their own people when there
is genocide in Darfur systematic rape in
Congo repression in Burma there must be
consequences yes there will be
engagement yes there will be diplomacy
but there must be consequences when
those things fail and the closer we
stand together the less likely we will
be faced with the choice between the
armed intervention and complicity in
oppression this brings me to a second
point the nature of the peace that we
seek for peace is not merely the absence
of visible conflict only a just peace
based on the inherent rights and dignity
of every individual can truly be lasting
it was this insight that drove drafters
of the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights after the Second World War in the
wake of devastation they recognized that
if human rights are not protected peace
is a hollow promise and yet too often
these words are ignored for some
countries the failure to uphold human
rights is excused
by the false suggestion that these are
somehow Western principles foreign to
Loken local cultures are stages of a
nation's development and within America
there's long been a tension between
those who describe themselves as
realists or ID lists attention that
suggests a stark choice between the Nair
pursuit of interests or an endless
campaign to impose our values around the
world
I reject these choices
I believe that peace is unstable where
citizens are denied the right to speak
freely or worship as they please choose
their own leaders or assemble without
fear pent up grievances fester and the
suppression of tribal and religious
identity can lead to violence we also
know that the opposite is true only when
Europe became free did it finally find
peace America has never fought a war
against a democracy and our closest
friends our governments that protect the
rights of their citizens no matter how
callously defined neither America's
interests nor the worlds are served by
the denial of human aspirations so even
as we respect the unique culture and
traditions of different countries
America will always be a voice for those
aspirations that are universal we will
bear witness to the quiet dignity of
reformers like unsung kuchi to the
bravery of Zimbabweans who cast their
ballots in the face of beatings to the
hundreds of thousands who have marched
silently through the streets of Iran it
is telling that the leaders of these
governments fear the aspirations of
their own people more than the power of
any other nation and it is the
responsibility of all free people and
free nations to make clear that these
movements these movements of hope and
history they have us on their side let
me also say this the promotion of human
rights cannot be about exhortation alone
at times it must be coupled with
painstaking diplomacy I know
that engagement with repressive regimes
lacks the satisfying purity of
indignation but I also know that
sanctions without outreach condemnation
without discussion can carry forward
only a crippling status quo no
repressive regime can move down a new
path unless it has the choice of an open
door in light of the cultural
revolutions horrors Nixon's meeting with
Mao appeared inexcusable and yet it
surely helped set China on a path where
millions of its citizens have been
lifted from poverty and connected to
open societies Pope John Paul's
engagement with Poland created space not
just for the Catholic Church but for
labor leaders like lek Valenza Ronald
Reagan's efforts on arms control and
embrace of perestroika not only improved
relations with the Soviet Union but
empowered dissidents throughout Eastern
Europe there's no simple formula here
but we must try as best we can to
balance isolation and engagement
pressure and incentives so that human
rights and dignity are advanced over
time
third adjust peace includes not only
civil and political rights it must
encompass economic security and
opportunity for - true peace is not just
freedom from fear but freedom from what
it is undoubtedly true that development
rarely takes root without security it is
also true that security does not exist
where human beings do not have access to
enough food or clean water or the
medicine and shelter they need to
survive it does not exist where children
can't aspire to a decent education or a
job that supports a family the absence
of hope can rot a society from within
and that's why helping farmers feed
their own people or Nations educate
their children and care for the sick is
not mere charity it's also why the world
must come together to confront climate
change there's little scientific dispute
that if we do nothing we will face more
droughts more famine more mass
displacement all of which will fuel more
conflict for decades for this reason
it's not merely scientists and
environmental activists who call for
Swift and forceful action its military
leaders in my own country and others who
understand our common security hangs in
the balance
agreements among nations strong
institutions support for human rights
investments in development all these are
vital ingredients in bringing about the
evolution that President Kennedy spoke
about and yet I do not believe that we
will have the will the determination the
staying power to complete this work
without something more and that's the
continued expansion of our moral
imagination an insistence that there's
something irreducible that we all share
as the world grows smaller you might
think it would be easier for human
beings to recognize how similar we are
to understand that we're all basically
seeking the same things that we all hope
for the chance to live out our lives
with some measure of happiness and
fulfillment for ourselves and our
families and yet somehow given the
dizzying pace of globalization the
cultural leveling of modernity it
perhaps comes as no surprise that people
fear the loss of what they cherish in
their particular identities their their
race their
and perhaps most powerfully their
religion in some places this fear is led
to conflict at times it even feels like
we're moving backwards we see it in the
Middle East as the conflict between
Arabs and Jews seems to harden we see it
in nations that are torn asunder by
tribal lines and most dangerously we see
it in the way that religion is used to
justify the murder of innocence by those
who have distorted and defiled the great
religion of Islam
and who attacked my country from
Afghanistan these extremists are not the
first to kill in the name of God the
cruelties of the Crusades are amply
recorded but they remind us that no holy
war can ever be a just war for if you
truly believe that you are carrying out
divine will then there is no need for
restraint no need to spare the pregnant
mother or the medic or the Red Cross
worker or even a person of one owns
faith such a warped view of religion is
not just incompatible with the concept
of peace but I believe it's incompatible
with the very purpose of faith for the
one rule that lies at the heart of every
major religion is that we do unto others
as we would have them do unto us
adhering to this law of love has always
been the core struggle of human nature
for we are fallible we make mistakes and
fall victim to the temptations of Pride
and power and sometimes evil even those
of us with the best of intentions will
at time fail to right the wrongs before
us but we do not have to think that
human nature is perfect
for us to still believe that the human
condition can be perfected we do not
have to live in an idealized world to
still reach for those ideals that will
make it a better place the non-violence
practiced by men like Gandhi and King
may not have been practical or possible
in every circumstance but the love that
they preached their fundamental faith in
human progress that must always be the
North Star that guides us on our journey
for if we lose that faith if we didn't
dismiss it as silly or naive if we
divorce it from the decisions that we
make on issues of war and peace then we
lose what's best about humanity we lose
our sense of possibility we lose our
moral compass like generations have
before us we must reject that future as
dr. King said at this occasion so many
years ago I refuse to accept despair as
the final response to the ambiguities of
history I refuse to accept the idea that
the isness of man's present condition
makes him morally incapable of reaching
up for the eternal oughtness that
forever confronts him let us reach for
the world that ought to be that spark of
the divine that still steers within each
of our souls
somewhere today in the here and now in
the world as it is a soldier sees he's
outgunned but stands firm to keep the
peace somewhere today in this world a
young protester awaits the brutality of
her government but has the courage to
march on somewhere today a mother facing
punishing poverty still takes the time
to teach her child scrapes together what
few coins she has to send that child to
school because she believes that a cruel
world still has a place for that child's
dreams let us live by their example we
can acknowledge the depression will
always be with us
and still strive for justice we can
admit the intractability of deprivation
and still strive for dignity clear-eyed
we can understand that there will be war
and still strive for peace we can do
that for that is the story of human
progress that's the hope of all the
world and at this moment of challenge
that must be our work your honor thank
you very much